why is the sky blue Rayleigh scattering
everyone and their mothers done that
video do you have any 7s Go Fish
but why isn't everything blue why isn't
the sky purple fine I'll do the video do
you have any tens Go Fish
this episode was made possible by
generous supporters on patreon
hey crazies it's real easy to be
dismissive with an explanation it's a
century old especially when there are
already this many videos about it but
now the question clone is asked some
deeper questions about it I've got
something to add let's do this as I
mentioned earlier the blue sky is caused
by something called Rayleigh scattering
named after John Williams strut 3rd
Baron Rayleigh otherwise known as Lord
Rayleigh Rayleigh is a peerage of
nobility named after a market town near
where his family was from he inherited
it from his father who inherited it from
his mother
you know nobility stuff this doesn't
actually matter the point is he started
thinking about this all the way back in
1871 and didn't put it all together
until 1899 which is what like 120 years
ago we've known about this a long time
is what I'm saying the explanation goes
something like this one direct light
from the Sun enters the atmosphere it
begins to scatter around
however this scattering is color
dependent higher frequency visible light
that means light near the blue end of
the visible spectrum is scattered almost
ten times as much as light near the red
end of the spectrum which is great no
but like why why does the color even
matter to answer this we're gonna have
to go a little deeper into how
scattering actually works I talked a
little bit about scattering in this
video but that was for solid surfaces
the Earth's atmosphere is a gas almost
entirely nitrogen and oxygen gas to be
specific something about these molecules
must be important as it turns out both
nitrogen and oxygen gas have strong
residences in ultraviolet resonances
right I guess I should explain that a
little light
Buller otherwise is an electromagnetic
wave a disturbance in the
electromagnetic field the energy from a
wave like that can be absorbed by
electric charges like the ones you'd
find inside atoms and molecules when the
light wave encounters a molecule the
charges inside it will start wiggling we
say that wiggling is being driven by the
light and this is a very classical
effect no quantum mechanics necessary
Newton's second law is enough to
describe it the total force on something
determines its acceleration wiggling is
a type of acceleration since it's the
electron cloud doing most of that
wiggling this should be the mass of that
cloud as for the forces that depends on
how accurate we want to be lucky for us
even the simplest model will make my
point two forces is enough one force is
the driving force from the light wave
it's an electric force because light is
an electromagnetic wave the other force
is called a restoring force it comes
from the bond that holds the electrons
in the molecule resonances yes yes what
we're getting there notice these two
frequencies are different the one in the
driving force is the frequency of the
light the one in the restoring force is
the resonance of the molecule that's the
frequency the molecule naturally wants
to wiggle at the closer the frequency of
light is to that resonance the bigger
the wiggle since color is directly
related to frequency the color matters
so how do we get from absorbing to
scattering that wiggling creates its own
light as we said earlier a wiggle or
vibration is a type of acceleration but
accelerating charge emits light that's
how light is made yes for real when the
incoming light mix the molecule wiggle
that wiggle creates its own light except
this one dimensional picture isn't quite
accurate the truth is we live in a
three-dimensional world and that new
light goes out in almost all directions
it's called dipole radiation and it's
very relevant to Rayleigh scattering
let's keep things as simple as possible
and imagine sunlight as a bunch of
parallel wave fronts they represent the
peaks in the electromagnetic wave when
they encounter an air molecule that
molecule will absorb some of the energy
and emit its own light with wave fronts
that look like this its emitted in every
direction except the wiggle axis but
don't forget about the resonance because
the molecules wiggle more when the
frequency of light is near that
resonance more of that light will get
scattered there's a color preference and
as we mentioned earlier the resonances
for nitrogen and oxygen are in the
ultraviolet range since blue was closer
to ultraviolet than red blue light
scatters more almost ten times more is
not the whole story you got talking
about wave interference you're right as
usual the truth is Rayleigh scattering
only happens in the upper atmosphere
it requires the molecules be very far
apart and randomly placed down in the
lower atmosphere near the surface of the
earth the molecules are only three
nanometers apart but the wavelengths of
visible light are in the hundreds of
nanometers that means we also need to
worry about wave interference if all
these molecules are becoming their own
little radiators and their spacing is
only a hundredth of the wavelength then
the chances of one molecule being half a
wavelength away from another are
extremely high two waves that are half a
wavelength out of phase will interfere
and cancel each other
it's called destructive interference
this will happen most places throughout
the air leaving only the forward moving
sunlight solids and liquids are even
denser than that hundreds or even
thousands of times denser that's why in
most substances there's only one path to
the light the refracted path to stop
this kind of interference we need the
density of the air to be extremely low
the molecules need to be separated by at
least a whole wavelength for Rayleigh
scattering to occur and not cancel
itself that only happens in the upper
atmosphere all the blue you see in this
image is coming from up near space the
light only scatters around for a bit as
it reaches denser and denser air its
path straightens out by then though the
blue is coming from all directions also
technically that the sky isn't blue it's
bluish white while blue is being
scattered more all the colors are being
scattered a little bit all the colors
together make white but white dominated
by blue is bluish white this also
explains why the Sun looks yellow ish
when it's actually pure white the direct
light from the Sun is missing the blue
because it got scattered away to the
rest of the sky also also sunset and
sunrise look yellow and orange for the
same reason the light travels through
the upper atmosphere longer at that
angle which means more Rayleigh
scattering so much in fact that the blue
is scattered away from your eyes
completely but why is this guy blue and
not purple right right I almost forgot
okay one last thing before we finish up
you can see from the visible spectrum
that there really isn't much purple
purple or violet is the color on the
very very edge right around 400
nanometers it's actually so close to the
edge of the human visible range that
some people can't even see it
the purple colors that most people see
are just combinations of red and blue
like this magenta color rather than
actual monochromatic purple the sky is
scattering ultraviolet light to a lot
more than visible light actually the
only reason the sky isn't purple is
because purple isn't very visible it's
there what we just can't see it so why
is the sky blue it's blue because of
Rayleigh scattering in the upper
atmosphere sunlight drives the motion of
electron clouds inside of air molecules
that wiggling generates its own light
that goes out in all directions
since these molecules resonate in ultra
violet blue scatters far more than red
if the molecules are far enough apart
this new light will continue to scatter
and ultimately arrive at your eyes from
all directions which makes the sky
appear blue from all directions and now
you know better wait why did I just say
that anyway did I go deep enough for you
let us know in the comments thanks for
liking and sharing this video a special
thanks goes out to fabio Manzini
for being one of our new orderlies on
patreon I can't thank my patreon patrons
or channel members enough for all their
help but I try my best with perks like
monthly live Q&A pledging even one
dollar a month gives you access so
thanks to all my supporters for making
this channel and frankly my life
possible don't forget to subscribe if
you'd like to keep up with us and until
next time remember it's okay to be a
little crazy to everyone in the last
video going on about multilinear maps
are hoping for a more math oriented
explanation of tensors tied in a former
host of PBS infinite series has a blog
post you should check out link in the
doobly-doo anyway thanks for watching
wait question flown stole my turn that
mother